last week we met two women who've broken
through in the college football coaching
ranks Heather Marini coaches
quarterbacks at Brown University and
Mimi Bolden Morris is a graduate
assistant on the University of Michigan
staff today in college soccer another
woman could make history by guiding her
men's team to a championship Charlie
Demar introduces us to coach Julianne
sich
pop off the pawn here the University of
Chicago men's soccer team is stacked
with all Americans and Veteran leaders
get four balls going but it's their
rookie head coach who's making history
it gives young girls something to Aspire
to if they can see it they can dream it
they can believe it and then they can
aspire to be that attack the space and
play from the sideline coach sich guided
the university to an undefeated record
and number one seed in the division
three final four making her the first
female to coach a men's soccer team to
the championship tournament just
starting to get up but sich's Journey
started as a five-year-old girl playing
on boys teams sich maintaining
possession sich working her way to the
corner of the box and continued as a
professional player in Australia Sweden
and the US she took over the Maroons in
April and became one of only two women
coaching in NCAA D3 men's soccer team
yes I've coached a lot of young girls
but I've also worked with a lot of young
boys as well and I think at the end of
the day you're coaching athletes have
you ever had a female coach no Griffin
wada is a senior and team captain I
don't think it was ever he huge pressing
thing that she was a woman she's just a
calm presence I've had a lot of coaches
in the past who are yelling on the
sideline who are freaking out at the ref
while it's a first for most of the team
they are quick to tell you that gender
has nothing to do with winning good
touch Mikey once we step on the field
our play speaks for itself and speaks
for her coaching abilities and to coach
sitch gender doesn't really have much to
do with coaching either what is your
hope in sort of opening a door for other
female coaches every coach has something
different to offer so I think really
just like in general opening everything
up to just see like finding a best coach
that fits regardless of gender in
different situations you know just
opening up the doors for everybody still
pressing cross back post header goal now
that she's made history sich can make
more today becoming if the Maroons win
the first woman to coach a men's soccer
team to a national championship for CBS
Saturday morning Charlie Demar Chicago
and if there's a first there's a next
and Jeff I know you weren't here last
week but we talked with the women
coaches that we had and with their
players this idea that it's about making
a player better making a team better
when you're an athlete you just want to
win that's it sounds right and there's a
couple big soccer games today yeah